jay-j Stankiewicz is the Bears insider
for our friends at the regional Sports
Network NBC Sports Chicago he's joining
us right here on the Rich Eisen show
he's also the voice of the under Center
podcast how are you JJ I'm great Rick
how are you I'm doing fine weird I I say
this this decision was made when they
acquired Nick Foles but I give the floor
to the insider what do you say on this
front
yeah they had made they've come to this
decision that they're not going to pick
up Michos if your option I think the
Knicks holds the decision to trade for
him essentially solidified it but they
had been moving this way for a while you
know look the the film doesn't lie with
what mitch has done you can talk about
how the rest of the Bears often didn't
perform up to the level I hope
especially a tight end and offensive
line but it comes down to quarterback
play and admit just did not meet the
expectations that the Bears placed on
him so there's really no reason to pick
up his fifth your option even before
they traded for fold because you're
risking him being bad and I'm getting
hurt and then being on the hook for 24
million in 2021 for a bad quarterback
what this does is and this is in tandem
with the fulls traded they're also
trying to motivate Mitch they're trying
to tell him hey you know we've given you
this job for the last three years
essentially now you've got to go out and
earn it and your career is really on the
line here so us trading for Nick Foles
us not picking up your fifth year option
is also trying to send a message to him
to try to light a fire under him to see
if that finally brings out the guy they
thought they were getting three years
ago so um where did it go wrong oh boy
definitely no I guess I mean look I know
that's kind of a harsh way to put it but
when you draft somebody second overall
you're you're gonna pick up their fifth
year option because you draft someone's
second overall certainly when in year
one with there is new head coach he's
looking stellar this something's gone
wrong where has it gone wrong
so it a lot of it is fit and when the
Bears drafted michka Biscay in 2017 it
was nowhere near the right fit for him
they had a coach in John Fox who was
still trying to save his job so when
Mike Glennon was awful for the first
four game the season Fox put Mitch in
earlier than he should have because he
was trying to win some games to keep his
job so the the structure around Mitch
also in 2017 was absolutely atrocious
and Kendall Wright was their leading
receiver that year he was out of the
league after that year they had he had
no one to throw to
he had no offensive scheme that was
conducive to what he needed but more
than anything he only started 13 games
in North Carolina he needed more time to
develop probably behind the scenes or if
not behind the scenes at least in a good
offensive scheme one that could play to
his strengths which what the Bears
offense 2017 did not do that at all from
a scheme perspective so then you get him
into Matt naggy system they kind of
erase a lot of what happened to 2017 but
now you're starting to see some of the
deficiencies that lie only in Mitch his
ability to process you know his ability
to read defenses not lock onto one or
two receivers go through his progression
make checks at the line all these
different things that a quarterback
needs to be able to do to be successful
and then 2019 was kind of his year of
just atrophy with him where things
started to go really wrong and now
you're starting to see him have really
sloppy footwork and miss wide open
receivers downfield you're starting to
see him make just mind-numbing decisions
with football
not just in where he's throwing it but
what he's doing with it when he's
running or taking a sack and it's it's
just gone downhill to the point where no
you can't pick up Mitch's phiffier
option and you have to go trade for Nick
Foles and the the thing that I just keep
going back to with it is that Mitch
would not be patch-up their homes or
deshaun Watson if he were in Houston or
Kansas City but I think he'd be a bit of
a better quarterback if he were from a
talent perspective he's got a lot of
the teams want he's mobile he's got a
strong arm he's displayed accuracy in
the past although that has waned in
Chicago and I just think that the Bears
did not set him up to succeed because
he's one of those quarterbacks who
needed everything around him to be right
to succeed and everything around him was
not right from the start and I think
that's kind of the root of a lot of the
problems here I mean they got rid of
John Fox if that's what you're referring
to and they did bring in somebody and
Matt Negi who won coach of the year with
him at quarterback and if it wasn't for
a double doing interestingly enough last
time nick foles won a game in the NFL
was then so you know put it all together
I mean was last year suddenly they
didn't have what they wanted what is it
I mean Jordan Howard went away or or you
know what I'm saying like how'd it go
from yeah we got a coach of the year guy
true Biscay is finally coming into his
own - Wow
it's never been right for him so 2008
team's offense was very simple it was
kind of the football 101 version of Matt
naggy scheme and I think and I don't
want to overstate the success Mitch had
in it because he was about a league
average quarterback in 2018 but Matt nag
even tried to build on that by saying
okay we got this guy who's that you know
sort of league average here let's try to
take him to the next level let's start
to expand this often you know when Matt
naggy left Kansas City Alex Smith was
running essentially the football 505
version of it so let's you take it up to
202 and see how he does and I think that
two of that jump in complexity in the
offense scrambled a lot of what Mitch
was able to do I mean he did he like
never took off and ran last year it he
was trying to do something that he
wasn't he was trying to be a guy that he
wasn't he never looked like he was
playing loose really until the Dallas
game in December and then that you know
kind of went away quickly when they went
up to Green Bay a week later I think
that you know it matt naggy maybe didn't
set Mitch up for as much success as he
could've but at the same point you've
got this guy who's drafted number two
overall who's got all this talent you
can't just keep running
a very simple offense that defensive
coordinators are able to figure out
pretty quickly and easily you've got to
try to expand it you've got to try to
put more on his plate
to grow his game it's not just as easy
as saying hey we we ran this off in 2018
that was pretty simplistic let's go
ahead and run it again in 2019 because
defensive coordinators know what's
coming you've got to try to add these
new wrinkles and I don't think mitch
handled those new wrinkles very well the
other aspect that I do want to give some
credence to is that their tight end play
was absolutely possible as seniors right
so they got nothing out of their tight
ends right and in Matt and Aggies
offense that is such an important
position you know if you look at Kansas
City with Travis Kelce Philadelphia yeah
Kurt and Dallas got hurt this type of
offense needs good tight end play the
Bears got absolutely none of it last
year that also impacted Mitch's play
last year is that why they're having
like a bachelor type setup for a tight
end right now it seems like that they're
having a reality show right I was kind
of them I don't think Adams gonna be
getting a rose the tight end play but
look you know they they've gone out and
they've they've tried to address that
position I don't know if they've
addressed it as well as they could've
well you know especially when you look
at the Jimmy Graham signing in his
decline in Green Bay but I like Cole can
that a lot he's grown I had a chance to
catch up with chip long it was offensive
his offensive coordinator at Notre Dame
and he said this guy is the real deal in
terms of his skill set what he can do in
terms of the blocking up side what he
can do in terms of his past catching up
side and the way that Shipp explained to
me is that this guy's not his focus at
Notre Dame was not just on football it
was on baseball academics and football
now you're getting a guy who's only
gonna be focused on one thing and that's
being the best tight end he can possibly
be in the NFL he's got a lot of upside I
think the Bears did that a pretty good
job getting him where they got him he's
a guy who I do think will impact this
offense because the other the other
number that always sticks out to me with
their tight end play isn't the number of
receptions they had last year or
whatever it may be the Bears were bottom
five in the league and running 12
personnel in 2019 the Eagles and Chiefs
were in the top five that number for the
Bears they've got to be able to get to
tight ends on the field a whole lot more
format and Aggies offense to really
start humming and I think in Jim
kolka met they at least will have the
ability to do that well and plus you
would know a JJ stank of it's the NBC
Sports Chicago Bears insider joining me
here on the richezza J you and anybody
who spent even a second in Chicagoland
knows that Notre Dame Fighting Irish
Fighting Irish football is the second
Chicago football team you know so to get
somebody from from from Notre Dame
they're sitting in Chicago is is a
popular move and I'm sure a bunch of
Bears fans know exactly is the same
thing with Jimmy Graham and and that is
all positive so I guess ballpark it for
me before I let you go sir what the next
steps here are and how you see this
playing out so the next steps for the
Bears are gonna be this quarterback
competition that that is the you know
one a thing for Matt naggy and I do
think it's going to be more open than
some folks might think you know when
they trade it for Nick Foles a lot of
people thought oh he's going to be the
immediately the starter I think foals
will be the weak one starter but he's
gonna have to earn it and I do think the
Bears are gonna have a relatively even
competition because that was also
another reason why they traded for foals
is that he allows them to have an open
competition because he knows the offense
or as Jameis Winston Andy Dalton Cam
Newton these guys don't know the offense
without offseason program blah blah blah
those guys aren't going to know the
offense so I think that it will be a
pretty open competition I would expect
foals to take the lead in that pretty
quickly when training camp starts and be
you know pretty clearly the week one
starter at some point in August and then
after that it's it's figuring out what
the offensive line can do to be better
because it was not all that good last
year they got rid of Harry East and who
is one of the best offensive line
coaches in football and replaced him and
the guy in one Cassio who knows Matt and
Agee but was out of the league last year
so can Juan Castillo fix the offensive
line that's another big question mark
big next step that they're gonna have to
see and then what their skilled position
looks like you know skilled positions in
terms of wide receiver tight end all
that and then mostly beyond all that is
just how will Matt naggy rework his
offense
try to fit who he has on this roster not
maybe fit an idea of what he thinks his
offense should look like I think there's
gonna be a huge year format naggy as in
his future as an NFL coach if Matt naggy
can figure out a way to get this bears
offense going with Nick Foles or mr.
Biscay as this quarterback man Aggies
gonna have a job for a long time in the
NFL but if they're if the Bears are
bottom five in the league on offense
again you know Matt nag he's not getting
fired after this year but he's gonna be
going into 2021 probably closer to the
hot seat than he may want so it's gonna
be a really huge year a pivotal year for
the Bears here in Chicago I think
they've done enough to get themselves
into contention in the NFC North again
maybe closer to Green Bay than they were
last year but a lot to us to come
together especially a quarterback for
the Bears to be a successful team in
2020 JJ thanks for the call really
appreciate it appreciate the insight
okay be well-written they get really bad
that's JJ stank of it's the NBC Sports
Chicago Bears insider and voice of the
under center podcast right here on the
Rich Eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here